un procedimiento de mamografía utiliza
rayos x- de dosis baja para ver y
detectar cambios en el tejido del seno
los senos de una mujer están compuestos
de tejido glandular y conductos grasa
tejido conectivo y vasos sanguíneos
si detecta un cambio en el tejido del
seno como un bulto o masa o si tiene 40
años como mínimo el médico puede
programar una mamografía antes de
realizar la mamografía asegúrese de que
sus senos y axilas estén limpios y no
usa desodorante ya que puede aparecer en
los rayos x- de la mamografía como
manchas de calcio por lo general una
mamografía tarda alrededor de 20 minutos
un técnico comenzará colocando uno de
sus senos entre dos placas especiales
las placas comprimirán el seno hasta
aplanarlo para que la cámara pueda
obtener una imagen clara de su tejido es
posible que sienta alguna molestia
durante la compresión pero sólo durará
algunos segundos luego este
procedimiento se repetirá en el otro
seno luego del procedimiento es posible
que se le pida que espere hasta que el
radiólogo revise los rayos x- ya que en
caso de ser necesario se le podrán tomar
más imágenes desde diferentes ángulos ya
que una mamografía es un procedimiento
ambulatorio simple podrá regresar a su
casa inmediatamente después del examen